Good morning.
Pray with me before we dive into the text today.
Heavenly Father, we are so thankful
that we get to come and worship you.
Pray Lord that today you would reveal to us
more about who you are, your goodness
and your faithfulness to us.
Pray all this in your name.
Amen.
All right.
Well, to start off today,
I'm just gonna go back to verse one
and I just wanna read verse one again
because there's a couple of things that stood out to me
as I studied this passage this week from verse one.
So Psalm 12 verse one says,
save, oh Lord, for the godly one is gone,
for the faithful have vanished
from among the children of man.
And I think that those words,
those three words at the beginning
really set the tone for what this passage is all about.
David is crying out, save, oh Lord, or help me God.
And that is the position,
his position to God is one of needing help
and recognizing that need for help.
So I want us to keep that in mind
as we move through the rest of this Psalm
because that is kind of the core
of what is being said here.
David's need for help and reliance upon the Lord.
I like how Charles Spurgeon put it
when he was expositing on Psalm 12 verse one.
He said, that help Lord is a short but sweet,
suggestive, seasonable and serviceable prayer,
kind of angel sword to be turned every way
and to be used on all occasions.
And isn't it true that that one phrase that help Lord
is actually usable in any occasion?
It's always applicable to our lives.
We always need his help.
One of my children, I won't say who it is,
but whenever she changes clothes,
she refuses help from anyone who tries to give it.
The other day she kept trying to put her head
into the armhole of one of her shirts.
Obviously it didn't fit and she kept getting frustrated
that it wasn't working.
When I offered to help, obviously she refused.
Her solution was that instead
she needed to take her headband off her head
and that maybe then that would work.
And eventually it did work.
Eventually she got her head to the right hole
and she put her shirt on backwards.
As kids, I think we can all look back on this and laugh
and we might see kids or have kids in our own lives
who act this similar way.
Not wanting help, wanting to do it on our own.
And that is often my tendency as well.
And so I ask myself and I ask you this question
kind of as leading into this text is,
do you tend to avoid asking for help?
Asking for help automatically puts us
in a state of dependency on someone.
Whoever it is we are asking for help from.
David here recognizes he needs God's help.
He comes right out of the gate and he starts with that.
So that's the first thing that I noticed in this first one.
The second thing is what is prompting David
to cry for help?
Well, if we look back at verse one,
David's crying out for help because the godly one is gone
and the faithful have vanished.
Now what does this mean?
Does this mean that there are no faithful,
not a single faithful person left in the entire world?
It's all gone.
Well, I don't think that's quite what David is saying.
The one could definitely make a case
that even David had his shortcomings
and had times where he was definitely not faithful to God.
There's a couple of reasons why I would lean that way.
One is there are two groups of people referenced here
and one of them is referenced more explicitly than the other.
The faithful who have vanished and the wicked
who prowl on every side as we see in verse eight later.
The second reason I think I'll lean this way
is because David remembers God's promises to him
and to Israel through him to establish his throne forever
and appoint a place for Israel, his people.
Later on in the story of Israel,
we find that there are similar sentiments echoed
by many prophets after David.
One being Elijah in First Kings 1910 when he says,
he's on the run from Jezebel right now.
He's hiding in a cave and he says,
I have been very jealous for the Lord, the God of hosts.
For the people of Israel have forsaken your covenant,
thrown down your altars, killed your prophets
with the sword and I even I only am left
and they seek my life to take it away.
And he felt this same feeling that David is saying here,
this I am alone, God, the faithful are gone.
I don't know which way to turn.
There's no one I can trust nearby.
It's helpful for us to remember that for Elijah
in verse 18 of that same chapter
that God promises to leave a remnant of 7,000 in Israel.
So we know that God's plan always contains
this remnant of people who are his people
who he will not leave and not forsake.
We also hear this a similar type of message from Micah
in Micah 7 verses 2 through 6.
So I'm gonna turn there.
If you have a Bible you wanna turn with me.
I think this is a really good parallel passage
to Psalm 12 as well.
So I'm just gonna turn to Micah 7 verses 2 through 6
and walk through some of what he says there as well.
Micah 7 2 says,
The godly has perished from the earth.
There is no one upright among mankind.
They all lie in wait for blood
and each hunts the other with a net.
Their hands are on what is evil to do it well.
The prince and the judge ask for a bribe
and the great man utters evil desire of his soul.
Thus they weave it together.
The best of them is like a briar,
the most upright of them a thorn hedge.
The day of your punishment has come now.
Their confusion is at hand.
Goes on to talk more about how
it's hard to put trust in anyone else.
It's hard to even trust family members.
I think this sentiment is one that we can all
relate to somewhat, whether it might be a person
or it might even be in yourself,
where you have a hard time trusting the things
that you even feel or the things that you're thinking
or the things that are coming out of someone's mouth
and it's so difficult to know what is real.
And so as we kind of look at this passage Psalm 12
in these two different groups,
the wicked and the wicked.
It's the wicked that are described here in the faithful.
I wanted to just keep our mind on what is David's heart cry
for God to help?
Why is he asking for help?
What does he need for help?
And what can we learn about the faithful?
What can we learn about the wicked?
And what can we learn about the Lord ultimately?
So let's take the wicked first.
What can we learn about the wicked from this chapter?
Well, to start off, they do not seek after God.
David here is seeking after God's help,
crying out, save, oh Lord, the wicked
are not seen asking for God to save them.
Instead in verse four, it says,
with our tongue we will prevail,
our lips are with us, who is master over us.
They see themselves as their own master.
In other words, they think they're smart enough
to use their words to get what they want.
So second, how is it that they use their words?
Well, in verse two, it says,
they utter lies to their neighbor
with flattering lips in a devil heart they speak.
So they seek to use their words to manipulate others
in order to get whatever it is they want.
They're hypocrites, they say whatever is convenient to them,
it's hard to trust them.
Being around someone like this is like walking on eggshells.
And I can honestly think of many times in my life
where flattery seems like the better course of action
than honesty.
And so if you look at this and you look at like,
okay, well, what does it mean to have flattering lips?
There's really two sins, I guess you could say,
that are underneath that term.
One is this flattery that is external.
So it might be this building someone else up
and praising someone else, not for the sake
of just building them up, but ultimately,
it's kind of like trying to get whatever it is they want.
So I'm gonna build you up so that I get what I want
in this secretive kind of way.
This using our words to manipulate other people
in ways that they might not even notice.
You might say to yourself, after all,
it's just like a little white lie.
What harm could it cause?
Who is it going to hurt?
And sometimes it might seem like the better course
of action than honesty,
while secretly the true motivation is maybe just
to make people think better.
David feels that he cannot trust the words
of anyone around him in this moment.
There's no one else that he can trust.
The second kind of sin, I think that's called out here
in the Wicked is the sin of pride.
It's the using your words to build yourself up
even at the expense of everyone else.
And so another thing that we see in the Wicked
is that in verse three says,
may the Lord cut off all flattering lips,
the tongue that makes great boasts.
They use their words here to boast about themselves,
ultimately at the cost of others,
or more specifically, when we get to verse five,
at the expense of the poor and needy.
I'm gonna pause here.
This is a tough word too,
because as I think about my own life
and times when I've used my words,
I often am thinking only about what I gain or myself.
So it's humbling to come to this text
and hear this description of the Wicked
as this prideful arrogant or flattering other people.
C.S. Lewis in his book,
The One Near Christianity,
referred to pride as the great sin.
He called it out as the utmost of evil.
And one of his main reasons for doing that
can be summarized here.
He says, pride gets no pleasure out of having something
only out of having more of it than the next man.
We say that people are proud of being rich
or clever or good looking, but they are not.
They are proud of being richer or clever
or better looking than others.
If someone else became equally rich or clever
or good looking, there would be nothing to be proud about.
It is the comparison that makes you proud,
the pleasure of being above the rest.
So the proud are boastful because they see themselves
as better than others.
And they ultimately boast in order to call attention to it.
And because pride is by its very nature competitive,
it becomes necessary to boast in oneself
at the expense of those in worse condition around them.
So what is the third thing?
How do they, what is it that they use their words to do?
So we know that they are using their words for pride
to build themselves up.
Well, in verse five, we see that they use their words.
Ultimately, it says, because the poor are plundered
and because the needy grown.
And I think this comes immediately after talking
about how the wicked use their words.
It's gotta be connected, that the wicked are using
their words ultimately for the sake of boasting
or building themselves up even at the expense of others.
So we see this description of what the wicked person is like.
What does this chapter say about the opposite
or the faithful?
Well, it's interesting.
The faithful, they first of all, I think we can see the faithful
in the example that David is putting forward here.
The faithful first are seeking help from the Lord,
starting with as we looked at earlier,
David begins with acknowledging his dependence on the Lord
and asking for his help.
And he knows that it is the Lord who saves ultimately.
Secondly, they boast in the Lord.
They use their words to build up the Lord
or say how good he is rather than build themselves up.
It's interesting how it says it here.
I'm gonna go ahead and read this back in verse six.
The words of the Lord are pure words like refined,
like silver refined in a furnace on the ground,
purified seven times.
You, oh Lord, will keep them.
You will guard us from this generation forever.
He's recognizing that it's the Lord's words,
the Lord's words that are building up,
the Lord's words that are good, and it's not our own words.
So if they boast in the Lord,
you may recall last week that Brandon preached on Psalm 11
and the holiness of hunkering down.
If you weren't here, go listen to it.
In his sermon, he referenced the refinement of silver
in relation to the testing of the righteous through fire.
Here we see that same metaphor of refinement of silver,
but specifically related to the words of the Lord.
And I think there's a reason that these
are a little bit connected in ways
that I didn't really understand before this.
See, I did kind of a deep dive on how silver is refined.
And if any of you know how silver is refined,
then bear with me, because I don't know anything
beyond what I learned from a couple YouTube videos
and some Googling.
But it's really cool.
There's actually not a whole lot of silver
in any of the ore that has originally
brought up out of the earth.
In fact, it's really less than 1% silver
most of the time, very little.
It's often more like copper.
It's the rock that goes with it.
It's everything else that makes up the ore
that is initially mined.
Before being refined, it's just copper led.
And then after they put the copper or this lead,
this ore into the furnace,
and it kind of slowly, it's called electrolytic refining
and the copper slimes gradually accumulate at the bottom.
The slimes are made up of what is like 20% silver.
So it takes time.
It's not all silver yet.
That is then fired in a furnace
and it slowly made into what's called an anode,
which is kind of a block of unrefined silver.
That anode is then put into a bath
of silver nitrate, like a solution,
with another block of pure,
refined silver.
And by putting them together in the same bath
and running an electrical current through it,
it slowly breaks the silver down from the unrefined silver
and adds it to the refined block of silver.
What you get as a result
is you get this beautiful piece of metal
that is 99.9% refined silver.
Now here it says the Lord's words
have been refined seven times.
So what does that mean?
That means 99.99999% silver.
It's very silver.
It's just about the best block of refined silver
you could possibly imagine.
And it is interesting that we are also being refined
like a block of silver.
And I like to think of this as we were put in that bath,
a crude unrefined block of silver.
But when we put ourselves there with the Lord's words,
the one who is the ultimate block of refined silver
that it slowly then refines us over time.
That's not easy to take.
It's not comfortable to be refined in silver.
I mean, it's breaking down of different blocks off of us.
But I think it's a cool picture
of what the Lord's words are really doing to us
in refining.
So we see that the faithful, they seek help from the Lord.
They boast and the Lord or use their words
to ultimately glorify the Lord.
Third, they wait for the Lord's provision.
David here recalls the promises of God.
In verse five, the Lord responding to the poor and needy
says, I will arise, says the Lord.
I will place him in the Lord.
I will place him in the safety for which he longs.
David's recalling that the Lord is the one
who will provide for his people.
He will guard them.
He will keep them safe.
So David is modeling for us that ultimately
being faithful is waiting for the Lord.
And now after studying a Psalm like this,
I often find myself trying to determine
where I fall in this passage.
I may think on some days I'm definitely striving
to be faithful.
On other days, I recognize my actions come up short.
I may be more aligned with the wicked.
However, you might have noticed
that David never really even mentions the faithful
in this passage, aside from stating that they
have vanished.
Instead, like the faithful, his focus is on the Lord.
If you look back, you might have noticed this pattern.
It says the wicked utter lies with flattering lips.
The wicked say they will prevail.
The wicked question who is master over them.
The wicked plunder the poor.
The wicked prowl on every side.
The wicked is one of the actors here we see.
But when talking about the Lord,
David says no, but there's no,
the faithful do X in our passage today.
Instead, it's made the Lord cut off all flattering lips.
The Lord will arise.
The Lord will place the poor and needy in safety.
The Lord's words are pure.
The Lord will keep them guarded.
Ultimately in our passage today,
the Lord is the actor throughout the entire Psalm.
And it's his actions being contrast with that of the wicked.
The faithful are merely calling to the front
what the Lord is doing.
As we stated in our opening scripture today,
his words will stand forever.
As we sang in the song earlier today,
the Lord is the one who will never,
no, never, no, never forsake.
To him, the honor and glory and power forever.
Or to borrow a quote from Tim Keller,
the Bible is not about us.
The Bible is about him.
Or from Revelation 712,
where the angels fall on their faces before God
singing amen, blessing and glory and wisdom
and thanksgiving and honor and power and might
be to our God forever and ever, amen.
So what are we to do?
How should we respond to this?
If this passage is all about the Lord
and David models for us something of what faithfulness is,
how can we respond to that wonderful truth
that the passage is all about God?
Well, I'm gonna flip back to Micah 7 here
because again, I love the way that he ends up
coming to this same conclusion.
So in Micah 7, remember he talked about
all of these same things that David is feeling,
feeling alone, feeling like he can't trust anyone,
feeling like he has no one to go to.
And picking up in verse 7, Micah says,
but as for me, I will look to the Lord.
I will wait for the God of my salvation.
My God will hear me.
Rejoice not over me, oh my enemy.
When I fall, I shall rise.
When I sit in darkness, the Lord will be a light to me.
I will bear the indignation of the Lord
because I have sinned against him
until he pleads my cause and executes judgment for me.
He will bring me out to the light.
I shall look upon his vindication.
You see, Micah recognizes rightly that it is only
through his waiting for the Lord and looking to the Lord
that he can ultimately end up on the side of the Lord
because he recognizes that he has sinned against him.
But God, the actor in this whole passage
is the one who saves.
So we should have confidence that the Lord will preserve us
acknowledging our known sinfulness,
sinfulness that can only be forgiven by God.
He is the one that will plead our case,
not our own words, but his words, which are pure.
So today, right now, I ask you this question.
Are you striving to be exalted among the children of man
as we saw in verse eight of the Psalm?
Or are you looking to the Lord and waiting for him to trust,
him trusting that he will keep and guard you forever?
And I'll repeat David's first line again as well,
save, oh Lord.
Let's pray.
Father, we are completely dependent upon you.
To save us, to keep us, to grow us, to refine us.
Lord, help us to have a posture of dependence.
Remind us of all of the things that you do.
Help us to recognize you as the actor
and help us to wait, to look for you
and to follow you, Lord.
Pray all this in your name.